تداعيات خيبه الامل التي اصابت الجمهوريين
في الولايات المتحده لا تزال مستمره بعد
انتخابات التجديد النصفي واشنطن بوست قالت
ان الجمهوريين يواجهون موقفا اشبه
بالماءزق الوجودي وهم يحاولون معرفه من
يستطيع ان يعبر بالحزب الى بر الامان
الصحيفه اشارت الى ان المحادثات الخاصه
بين المانحين للحزب تركز على ما يعتقدون
انها قد تكون افضل فرصه لهم لتهميش ترامب
ترامب بنظرهم ساهم في عدم تولي حزبه زعامه
مجلس الشيوخ وتحقيق مكاسب اقل من المتوقع
في مجلس النواب والسبب هم المرشحون ذو
الاراء المتطرفه من الذين حققوا نتائج
سيئه من جانبه كسر ترامب صمطه بشان
اخفاقات الانتخابات النصفيه ليلقي باللوم
على زعيم الاقليه في مجلس الشيوخ مش مكان
ال اعتبر ترامب بان مكان الانفق الاموال
بشكل خاطئ ما ادى لهزيمه المرشحين كما انه
لم يقدم الدعم لعدد من المرشحين الذي
ندعمهم ترامب اكثر من مره دعت رامبل
لاقاله من منصبه وجدد دعوته هذا الاسبوع
عندما اعتبر ان السناتور ريكستوت سيكون
افضل شخص حاليا لقياده الجمهوريين بمجلس
الشيوخ رغم خساره مرشحين الاسبوع الماضي
ما زال ترامب صاحب شعبيه في حزبه نقلت
واشنطن بوست عن مخططين جمهورينا قولهم ان
نسبه تاييد الجمهوريين لترامب تصل الى 40%
[موسيقى]
لكن اذا قرر الجمهوريون تغيير ترامب فمن
ابرز المرشحين لخلافته واشنطن بوست حاولت
الاستقراء وزير الخارجيه السابق
المرتبه التاسعه
الخميس الماضي
وقال ان المرشحين الجمهوريين يتم انتخابهم
عندما يقدمون برامج
في الانتخابات التمهيديه عام 2016 اضافه
اليه في المركز الثالث
تجنب اغضاب ترامب خلال كتاب سيصدره غدا
لكنه قال في لقاء تلفزيوني ان خطوات ترامب
عرضت الكثيرين للخطر الى المركز الثاني
نجد هنا دونالد ترامب الذي يسعى للوصول
لولايه الثانيه له غير متتابعه او متواليه
للبيت الابيض اما المركز الاول فيحل في
حاكم ولايه فلوريدا وهو ران ديسانتس خاصه
بعد ان اتسح منافسه الديمقراطي بفارق 20
نقطه واظهر استطلاع اجرته يوجا الشهر
الماضي ان ديسانتس يبتعد ب 90 نقاط فقط عن
ترامب في حال ما اذا تواجهات في
الانتخابات التمهيديه للحزب الجمهوري لكن
ما راي المواطنين الامريكيين هذه شريحه
منهم
سنوات
كوفي